well distance education remains a
serious struggle for a lot of clark
county district families
but those with special needs students
are finding the situation
even more challenging eight news now
reporter kristen drummond shows us their
concerns
and also their educational rights
she's already struggling and it's
already only the third day renee parker
worries about her daughter victoria
an 8th grade student with an
individualized education program
or iep it was verified that she has to
be able to see it hear it
and then actually have somebody there
just
to show her how to do it an issue during
full-time distance education at home
there's a lot of stuff that i cannot
help her with right now i'm afraid that
she's just gonna fall between the cracks
a concern for other parents with special
needs children but
one single mother decided to quit her
job recently and stay home
when it became a choice of taking care
of my kid or going to work i chose my
son
the clark county school district
reopening plan addresses students with
disabilities
the website offers a broad overview of
their plan of support
i talked to my daughter's
case worker but she can only do so much
the legal aid center of southern nevada
says the pandemic should not change the
quality of children's education
the organization lists several
suggestions parents can add
in a child's iep there's just not enough
resources out here for these special
needs kits
making some families question their
child's success this year
for us parents that have the kids with
ieps and 504s
they need the extra special help legal
aid center of southern nevada will offer
a free special education rights class
starting monday
for more information visit our website
8newsnow.com
reporting in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now
now kristin also tells us that that
virtual class is going to cover a
variety of topics
including how to get your child
qualified for special ed
services